foreign
hey I'm Andrew and we're playing truth
or dare
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody from first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and welcome
back to another exciting episode of
Truth or dab the hot one special where
we give our guests two simple options
tell the truth or Escape it by eating a
death wing and today I'm very excited to
welcome Andrew Thomas and Darius Slayton
both representing the New York football
Giants coming off their first playoff
appearance since 2016 with a young
offense like this the future looks
bright Andrew Darius welcome to the show
thanks for having me appreciate you
having Andrew we're going to start with
you
player fashion has become such a part of
the game day experience you know you see
guys with their style walking through
the tunnel posted by almost every team
every Sunday thinking about your own
Giants teammates who gets off the best
tunnel fit picks and who gets off the
worst the best
I would go myself honestly you know what
I'm saying big guys not easy not easy
you know what I'm saying we can't go to
the store and just get everything we
want so you gotta you know put some time
in to put together and uh for the worst
uh I'm gonna go John Feliciano that's my
dog but I'm about to get on it right now
all right there we go through one
question no wings off the board Darius
gonna turn our attention to you point
blank is somebody who played with both
who spins a nicer more catchable ball is
it Eli Manning or Daniel Jones
[Music]
uh
uh gotta go with my goddamn Jones why
any reason uh
[Music]
yeah I want to eat a wing and I mean
that was a great ball they both do a
great ball but obviously I've had DJ my
whole career so
I'll go with him all right there we go
through one round moving on to the next
round and you know I think it's worth
pointing out that you guys not only
share a locker room with the Giants but
you guys also share Georgia roots and
then both played in the SEC before the
NFL Andrews you as an All-American at
Georgia Darius is a star-wide receiver
at Auburn Darius which SEC fan base has
the most annoying and obnoxious fans by
far theirs
Georgia's the worst fan base maybe in
the country not just the SEC what makes
it that annoying they think they're good
every year they think they're always
going to win when you go there is
terrible when they come to your place
they ruin your home stadium
not great Andrew any rebuttal to that or
is that sound on the nose I mean were
you winning does that happen that's
right that's right and you guys have
been winning you know now at the top of
college football I'm curious from your
unique vantage point on the throne which
SEC football program would you say is
most overrated most overrated
um
let's go with Tennessee Tennessee yeah
everybody always want Tennessee back
they want to say they're back put them
in the top ten and just to have a good
season
um have some good receivers you know
what I'm saying make a few plays and
down their back they're the best but you
know we come through and we humble them
every time so we're gonna leave it at
that all right so through two rounds of
very truthful truth or dabs so far let's
move on to round number three Darius
we'll go with you you know you've played
in New York long enough to know what
this media Market is like you know the
click bait headlines and the spicy hot
takes on all the sports TV talk shows
who's the pundit or outlet that you
would say talks about you and your team
in a way that's most unfair it was the
most unfair
oh
held out as long as he could Wing is
coming off the board
no horrible and Darius yeah you're a guy
who you like spicy food you're into hot
sauce
I'll say so going back in cleaning that
way impressive
one bite yeah yeah you don't go in that
extra mile go in that extra mile I
promise I wouldn't do that
I thought I'd eat the wings all right
Andrew you're coming off an All-Pro
season at tackle
wow I wouldn't have did that
which defensive end that you play
against in the NFC East would you say
has the weakest pass rush the weakest
um
by the way uh
this is round two around three we're
into round three actually we've made it
a nice long way all right let's see what
we got here there we go
I was sweating before I bit it
spicy there we go
down
all right moving on here to round number
four we're all on the same plane here
all in the same ground all on the same
footing and I understand that you guys
have both pursued majors in business
when you're in college and I know that
these are very difficult circumstances
but we're going to put some of that
Acumen to the test here with a little
pop quiz you guys can put your brains
together you can work together on this
here's the first question the process of
reducing the number of defects is
typically known in manufacturing by the
letters QC what do those letters stand
for
quality control
for the team there one more question and
we can get out of this round unscathed
all right this is crazy
what are the major categories of the
balance sheet are they depreciation
credit and interest or assets
liabilities and Equity the second one
assets liabilities and Equity yeah
the correct answer is
assets liability and Equity through the
round through the round and not a wing
off the board and here we are moving in
to the final round now this is going out
just before the Super Bowl this weekend
we have the Super Bowl coming up but at
the time of this taping we're going into
the conference Championship round so
there are four teams remaining the 49ers
Bengals Eagles and Chiefs we got to play
a one's gotta go between those teams
which of those teams is definitely not
raising the Lombardi trophy this Sunday
hmm I'm gonna go
San Fran because I think Philly gonna
win
the Eagles just because I don't want to
see it again
well there you have it a very truthful
episode of Truth or dab Andrew Darius
incredible performance very brave any
words for the fans before we get you
into an ice bath come give me one more
bite there we go let's show myself
oh my goodness don't come don't don't
know whatever this is just leave it
alone the last app don't touch it no
Andrew though
regret this later salute putting one on
for the fans Giants football look out
for it Andrew Darius incredible run good
luck next season guys
[Applause]
jeez
if I don't have this in my mouth my
tongue right you have to you get like
temporary relief but that was you going
that was you bringing it that was you
leaving it all on the field it doesn't
eat the whole Wing so you know I was
like
committed trying to be overachiever